para todos amico o se preferite in
questo nuovo video che fa vice altri
episodi di game tester dopo un mesetto
ormai un appuntamento fisso
ora comincia ragazzi in domino il già in
testa del mese che questo mese è stato
vinto da lorenzo da cefalù bravo lorenzo
c'hai un nome bellissimo complimenti che
ho scelto per il nome perché è bello
ragazzi a parte gli scherzi cominciano
con il gameplay di oggi ma prima di
cominciare sigla
i cartoni di oggi ragazzi and gamble per
chi non lo conoscesse il primo videogame
su gamble e battaglia ai birilli con la
palla da bowling in mezzo sembra
battaglia a job e riley ragazzi facciamo
la partitina giusto per capire
abbatti di tutti vabbè ragazzi a sto
punto scegliamo gamble che mi sembra il
più bilanciato usa vs di per muovere ma
posso muovermi proprio che figo ma è
fatto ora usa al mouse per puntare e
sparare al birillo cattivo
oddio quanto era cattivo questo birilli
a recupera la palla devo anche andare a
recuperar mila pad mazza che fastidio
non certo strazione anche quando mia
madre mi dice di ripulirla camera
devo anche andare a raccogliere la palla
fantastica come carino cioè nel senso di
sopravvivenza tipo spacco tutto vai così
ma i capelli che sono superato perché a
livelli e pensavo fosse senza fine usa i
tasti per cambiare ma non posso cambiare
il personaggio ma veramente ma dai ma
che bello quindi posso no vabbè ma è
fantastico spazio per schiacciare posso
schiacciare le robe belle
dio mio ragazzi sono diventato un
fenomeno cioè non sapevo di poter pasta
cosa ma e quindi è lei la tipa cosa fa
invece ognuno c'è la sua magia
fantastico non morirò neanche una volta
già lo so ciao
e stato bello ma è l'azienda la combo di
tre ragazzi
mamma mia è prodotto ucciderli la combo
di quattro fermi vuole fare come di
quattro dei cinque e vabbè troppo aveva
già o dio mi ha beccato no 26 morti
sette ho fatto una combo di sé mira
perfetta me va bene anche in biliardo
ciò stava pro hugin
i ragazzi mi hanno accerchiato la palla
non ce la faccio c'è una vita sola fa
una strage ho fatto mai così si ora è
così ma che ma che roba orobie oddio
quel è morto da solo è scemo grande
fratello è tutto difficile però è il
quarto era difficile 8 adesso ci sono
pure gli ostacoli fantastico sta
diventando difficile otto ragazzi però
ce la faccio
c'è dio mio spero di no come noi stanno
scherzando
ok meraviglioso ragazzi lei è veramente
lenta la non riesco a muovermi cos'era
una mossa da ballerina vai vai vai ma
cos'è questo allora l'avviso che mi sta
arrivando il nemico sono un genio ci
sono andato sopra ragazzi sono morti ve
lo dico sono morto questo già si grande
brava ragazza mi bravissima ok le palle
a multi palla cosa vuol dire cioè non
solo una baia addio così chi è quello
senti zio e ti devo schiacciare ok fuori
bravo frate avete una fine vi prego jolo
beh oddio si apre il tombino fantastico
della serie che se ci butta la palla è
lo sapevo ma io posso essere più genio
ma più genio a grazie grazie
non pensano magari dava stavo messo male
oddio ciao
e vabbè però loro non cadono come è sta
storia che cadi solo quando mi dei fas
comodo aiuto ha fatto una strada combo
per nove palla passa cosa vuol dire
addio a fantastic c'è il ragazzo io e la
fortuna siamo una cosa sola e per l'amor
di dio di realtà sono tutti gli istanti
non serve a niente
oddio oddio ok casinò ho fatto casino
meno male che lo dico non ce la fa ormai
non solo nomis incastrato aiuto aiuto
sia nessuno cavalcano dai non vale mi
serami sfasata pagina palla nel canale
ci riprovi giusto una guarda in realtà
ci vorrei riprovare però mancano un
sacco di livelli se no il video dura sei
anni quindi per ora direi che possono
includere qui con questo videogame devo
ammettere che fino adesso è stato uno
dei migliori che ho provato su cartoon
network perché uno dei più competitivi
sicuramente quindi da game tester mostra
provo la corda ragazzo li passiamo al
secondo gioco di oggi che schiva i
vestiti allora quando ragazzi che sarà
difficile battere quello di primario del
bowling perché
uno dei migliori sul serio fino adesso
risolve determinato sopra il record
mondiale di tempo passato in mutande
quel record ce l'ho io
credimi non lo batte nessuno ma la sua
famiglia nella tuta abbastanza farà come
contento di scappare senza le braghe
bravo zio eh vabbè acqui usa le frecce
per salire la grafica ragazzi e
fantastica perché hanno preso una foto
la foto di una casa vera fantastico a
devo schivare le i vestiti giusto solo
per il ballo e il gioco dell'anno ora
che al solo il ballo ma perché deve
cambiare lo scenario ragazzi evitiamo i
vestiti che meglio perfetto ma non è
così facile come sembra è legale ma io
sono un fenomeno nato quindi vado
velocissimo vai vai vai no stavo
scherzando che ricordo fatto 48 farò
anche 300 stavolta si accettano
scommesse su 300 di farisei 100 ragazzi
siamo a 100
addio oddio no no sono un idiota
mi ha messo ansia che saliva in fretta
ma scusate ragazzi non dico niente ma mi
sto concentrando l'ho presa seriamente
sta cosa
si si come no se mi sto scherzando vai
vai vai vai vai vabbè vabbè ma neanche
mia mamma mi rincorre così tanto con
l'annuncio le mutande c'è un nome che
gino senza mutande giro con le mutande
però regala 163 di arrivare a 300
trecento io l'ho detto e l'ho detto e lo
faccio non è che dico cose che poi non
faccio 160 doba the record basta in un
pad e retro 172 record record perché mi
prendono lega ma perché non potete
lasciarmi mutande questa c'avete contro
le mutande negozio ma ditelo prima ma
che ne so io dirò ti posso comprare gli
occhiali mettono in gioco le monete di
platino premio beh le cuffie se non
compro io le cuffie che c'ha le cuffie
prendi un passaggio da un palloncino
ragazzi io stavo arrivando a 200
facciamo 300 dai torniamo su 300
ma se così
ragazzi io stavo arrivando a 200
facciamo 300 dai torniamo su 300
stavolta lo faccio lo faccio lo faccio
ragazzi lo faccio non vale più record
del 200 di nuovo oltre 100 perché non
sapevo ci fossero le cose
ok che bello il palloncino tra l'altro è
bellissima no no no no no no no no no eh
vabbè veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce
veloce va beh ma impossibile ragazzi un
certo punto diventa impossibile da
ragazzi cappello di stagnola questo non
c'è moltiplicatore cosa vuol dire che
c'è più roba
ok allora con il moltiplicatore dovrei
riuscire ad arrivarci si spera
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye sea
si 200
ti prego trova qualcosa tra vanno a casa
ma nozze sì sì sì sì sì sì sì sì no no
sbloccato progaming progaming ho vinto
tutto dalla vita grazie mamma cosa ho
fatto cosa ho fatto sono troppo bravo
zio regalone posso solo è stata
l'esperienza videoludica più difficile
degli ultimi anni vi giuro complimenti
anche a gamble e descriva i vestiti e
veramente bene non che questo c'è tra i
due se la giocano comunque da soli
questi erano i videogame da gente sardi
questo mese
se volete partecipare anche voi come già
in testa del mese come ogni mese potete
trovare i giochi sul sito di cartoon
network ed essere anche voi vi è in
testa e tentare di vincere anche voi
l'edizione di game tester per il
prossimo mese
comunque sia ragazzi il video che state
vedendo verrà anche trasmesso su cartoon
network che state guardando questo video
da cartoon network da una forma in tv
dovrei riuscire a toccare i bordi dello
schermo del televisore così la smetto sì
la smetto e sarà anche presente sul
canale youtube di cartoon network come i
video dei v in the stairs vedere gazzoli
però non viene vi sia piaciuto a casa e
dove vi lascio con l'assenza sempre
piaciuto lasciato al momento è un mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e con
il video tratta descrizione se sono
riusciti sia che ci vediamo al posto
dello ragazzi sigla di chiusura
mai mai